right this is a probably one of the
oldest samples of aspirin company in
existence today in the UK it's one of
the first samples ever made in England
aspirin is a very common drug use for
pain relief and anti inflammation and
it's very very old and very very
effective this was given to me by my
next-door neighbor professor Jerry
Patton Dunne who was the professor Jesse
B professor in Nottingham and this is
handed down through the decades from the
original suggestively professor
Frederick kipping who made this sample
in 1911 so here he is I got a picture of
in the old guy actually we're going to
make a bit of aspirin because it's one
it's actually the first molecule I ever
made let's get to the lab and crack on
with it okay who's helping me do aspirin
James you wanna do aspirin
someone do something okay I'll do it
I'll start this is a salicylic acid this
is a starting material and what we're
going to do is isolate it but then we're
going to use a compound called a reagent
called acetic anhydride we're going to
add some to there then we're going to
microwave it just like we use a
microwave to heat up your food we're
going to use a microwave to heat up our
molecules take a syringe take some
acetic anhydride and run it down the
flask quite gently it's going on to the
salicylic acid and it's five millilitres
earned a sort of shake of that and I'm
just going to put in a little bit of
this phosphoric acid so this is clean I
wouldn't normally if it wouldn't have a
second anything dirty now I'm gonna put
a few drops and then it's going to be a
catalyst is it's going to speed up the
reaction to one two
three four five one for good luck yeah
why not so now we're going to move over
to our microwaves so now we're going to
put the flasks in the microwave chamber
and sits an equity company put the lid
back on 15 minutes at seventy five ish
degrees we've got to warm it up to get
the reaction going so now we are it so
heating up you can see it's going from
23 it's going up there quite quickly 20
30 degrees now so let's go back to the
office and we'll talk about the
background of aspirin well aspirins got
very close links to Nottingham and
obviously we're not in university and
you can see boots the chemists or
pharmacist which is now one of the
biggest chains in UK they manufacture
aspirin let's go back in time so let's
go to this molecule which is salicylic
acid so what we have here is a benzene
ring a carboxylic acid an acid group
here an alcohol group here now this
compound is actually derived from a
compound from nature from a willow tree
called salicin
and when you ingest salicin it gets
metabolized salicylic acid which is
actually an anti-inflammatory itself
okay so for many years people have been
using willow trees or willow bark to
treat inflammation and pain salicylic
acid which is the precursor to aspirin
when you saw me adding salicylic acid in
the flask with the seating anhydride so
what we're going to do the salicylic
acid is put this group on it which is an
acetal group and we're going to stick it
on here so we're going to swap this
hydrogen and put this on there so I'm
going to do that and this is what's
happening in the microwave now we've
taken an asset our group and capped it
onto this oxygen now this is aspirin
that's the molecule bought in the body
aspirin inhibits them just like the
biosynthesis of prostaglandins it
actually inhibits an enzyme it stops an
enzyme from working so this sits in an
enzyme and what it does it delivers this
group that we just stuck on and the
enzyme takes that group off and it can't
work anymore so it's as isolated the
enzyme stops it from working some
molecules cause information and cause
pain so if you can stop the manufacture
of these molecules then it's obviously
very good you know it's a good treatment
and aspirin does that so the acyl group
comes off
year but also the remaining part of the
salicylic acid this also sits in the
enzyme and also stops it from working so
there's actually two ways
so without the asset our group the
salicylic acid will have an effect it
will inhibit the enzyme or stop the
enzyme from working but when you deliver
this group as well it's like two for one
it's a bonus so it was first made by a
Frenchman called a Charles Frederick
Gerhart in 1853 which is quite a long
time ago but this was really just
forgotten really until Felix Hoffman
who's a chemist at Bayer Pharmaceuticals
he became interested in a girl hearts
work on aspirin and what he did he
reproduce go had synthesis and then he
went home to his dad he was suffering
from having a headache or information no
arthritis he he had and Hoffman go zi
dad have some of this he took it and hey
presto it relieved me of is their
symptoms and I Hoffman thought great
Eureka moment again you know yet the the
wiser he made the connection perhaps we
can make money out of this wonder drug
you know this new molecule and he went
back to Bayer convinced Bayer to
manufacture it and they patented it in
1900 and in Bayer made an absolute
fortune selling aspirin around the world
and in England we were buying this drug
from from Germany even to treat our
people then all sudden World War one
breaks out we don't become friends with
you know we fall out of ur friends with
Germany and then the supply of aspirin
of C stops so this is where professor
kipping comes in and Boots
Pharmaceuticals they decide to start
manufacturing aspirin for themselves and
obviously selling it to the Allies this
is why the plant was has started nothing
in in beeston in 1915 the production -
right and beginning a World War Ron one
really and Boots pharmaceuticals made a
quite a lot of money out of this and
this is why Nottingham University has a
professor boot or suggestive boot
professorship now which is the money was
that given by boots to start this up and
the actually the language university of
nottingham blonde was donated by
suggesting boot so you know it's we're
it actually tied into aspera in the
history of nottingham is so that's why
i'm quite interested in this wonder drug
how this molecule it change the world
this group here which is one of the
warheads so the aspirin is called an
asset our group so a for asset i'll spur
spi a lot comes from the name of the
willow plan
which was comes from and in just happens
to be a nice ending and it's quite
common the use of aspirin and that's how
the name came about okay so we're ready
to take it off the boil so you saw how
it was it's all dissolved now let's take
a single it looks like adds a clear oil
I can smell vinegar that's a good sign
so like 20 milliliters of water drop
that down the side slowly now that what
I'll do is destroy the acetic anhydride
its remaining then the stir a little bit
over good mixing now what we're trying
to do is get the aspirin to crystallize
out as a solid it might take a little
bit of effort sometimes they haven't
straightaway not always we might have to
heat it up one way to do it really well
do a crystallization to keep the mixture
very hot and then we cool it and during
that process the aspirin should
crystallize and give some really
beautiful looking crystals you see any
crystals off what I'll do I'll swirl it
see if you can see like a snowstorm
effect in there you see that yeah okay
so sometimes to help speed up
crystallization if you scratch the
inside of the flask sometimes it crashes
out fingers crossed
you see the whole the whole fuss getting
filled with aspirin okay the aspirins
crystallizing that just from scratching
it so that's inducing crystallization
yeah it's a is one of the things that
makes chemists really happy in that when
you see things out so when I scratch it
you can you're actually forming a nice
surface for the crystals to kind of
aggregate on so it just goes like to
grab on to really last I look at it and
so you're adding a swirl the flask pour
the content into the filter funnel just
hold it whoa see that you got some
aspirin
most quite a lot of it
as a bottle of aspirin so here's the
sample at Kings group made in 1911 and
here's a sample I just made in the lab
2010 almost 100 years between them and I
go say kipping sample looks a lot better
than mine
despite it being a lot older there we
have it side by side